Nancy just a taste of the madness going
on in the streets of San Diego here at
Comic Con the ladies of sharknado
dancing around our et sign and look at
that I click my fingers and wallah
they're here in the et sweet ladies good
to have you here
you know sharknado 3 ended with the
stars in space so for sharknado 4 the
fourth awakens how could they top that
we hit the set to find out well nado
ever in your wildest dreams we're making
sharknado 1 that you'd be here at
sharknado 4 no no to be frank and honest
I didn't think that even sharknado 1
would make it on TV did it ever the
franchise has experienced monster-sized
ratings and they're hoping for a repeat
with the fourth install bands are
integral in the success of this which is
why they were asked to determine the
fate of Tara Reid's character April you
know this movie was made popular by
social media we elicited the help of the
fans by SLM to hash tag April lips so
what's the verdict she listened and may
the force be with you she's not the only
one back for another bite I'm so
grateful to have David Hasselhoff back
with us The Hoff is just great to have
around that said he's the nicest guy
ever and this time they're taking over
the Vegas trip residents and tourists
are urged at this time to get inside
and for a movie franchise famous for its
cameos this hi mr. personal the force
awakens does not disappoint
run away from the sharknado